this here is a darkling beetle it lives
out here in the vast desert of Northwest
Utah and he's on the move way or - I
don't have a clue but I can tell you
about the town he's leaving behind
welcome to loosen Utah there's abandoned
cars weeds once in a while
train will pass through yep
there's not a whole lot here and loosen
well except for this man but who is this
man this man who lives in an airplane
hangar who flies a Cessna to get to his
closest friends who is this man this man
who lives in the middle of nowhere who
lives 25 miles from this bar but this
man inside who owns a bunch of guns
works with machines made this thing who
my name is Ivo dhatus K and this is what
I live as you've gathered this man isn't
from around loosen he grew up in
Czechoslovakia before the fall of the
USSR he didn't like it much it's kind of
hard to do anything the Communists were
in power there you cannot have your own
business it's kind of difficult to fly
there so I can I didn't feel like I
could be myself he really wanted to
leave the country but it wasn't easy
there was an Iron Curtain they like have
a machine gun towers and barbed wire to
keep you in they like to keep you so
when he was 24 he escaped the country
the only way he knew how
by flying across the border in his self
built airplane so I drove up close to
the border between Austria and some time
like at 3 o'clock in the morning I took
off and I just glided over to Austria
and I found myself Vienna International
Airport and I landed that and then I
just showed them my expired passport and
I asked for asylum and the world took
notice
I guess then I would have seen on this
thing like that before
so I think they liked it I like it
Ivo then moved to Los Angeles and built
up a successful airplane propeller
business but even LA couldn't fit his
big ideas I kind of needed a place to
test my other idea which is how to do it
in the middle of the city that's how I
found this place in Utah it was for sale
so I bought it and I've been here for
like eight years what was I was big idea
that brought him to loosen well it's
behind that door over there
inside sits in a propeller flying
machine able to lift off and land
vertically it's basically an airplane
helicopter hybrid of sorts it's kind of
funny looking but the damn thing
actually flies
so what's Ava's next big project the
solar powered aircraft an innovative
propeller design some kind of new way to
fly the next big one is that the
speargun idea which actually it was
better than I thought that doesn't
always work that way sometimes I get
really bad ideas
even while inventing new spear guns and
the like Ivo still finds the time to get
out of the house in fact that's him over
there hiking on the side of a mountain
it's just him nature and his customized
rifle
I think the gun is me because of the
mountain lions however treacherous the
hike it's always worth it you get a good
view of loosen it actually looks pretty
nice from here don't it
you know I still wonder why did that
Darkman beetle ever leave this place
maybe loosen wasn't right for the little
guy maybe it's escaped into the next
place where it can be itself farrago
though looks like this might be his last
stop come at ERISA this is what I always
wanted I kept escaping until I escaped
to listen and now I don't have anywhere
else to escape like man is stuck here
well no it's also a truce if you think
about it